[Music]
when you look incredible
why thank you yeah thanks for being here
that's inappropriate and I apologize now
I don't really I'll do it again what did
you just do it back to me I did what do
you how was your sound it wasn't as like
guttural as yours was like it's like an
old Jewish man yeah uh let's get started
I was told by my producer today that you
have a bone to pick with me I have no
idea what's going on so let's talk about
it and I'm finally here face to face
with you yeah
now um so you kind of ruined my first
relationship and my taste in men forever
okay um I both dislike and like where
this is going but I honestly don't know
what you're talking okay so here like
okay so my first relationship my first
love of my life um started out super
normal became a comedian because of this
guy so Conan Conan yeah no so he would
what he would watch the show oh my god
like religiously like he TiVo it we
watch it at night
then we TiVo it watching the next
morning with a cup of coffee like watch
like old SNL's you were on like old
archive footage and I was just like well
I don't get it I was basically just like
jealous okay I was getting between you
and your man exactly and I'll but he's
not even that funny was it dancing
hell
[Applause]
there's high comedy women find that
highly erotic
I don't know we're here imprinted
interrogation
right wait a minute so this guy gets a
little obsessive about me understand a
bar yeah and then you find like that I
was just I was basically like a jealous
girlfriend cuz you took time away from
me and I secretly really loved you but
like I had to like I hated you and right
I wish the story was you loved me and he
was jealous frankly that would be a
better story for me personally oh now
it's all come back around and I'll and I
do love you thank you so much when I
hear it I turn it around that's and what
about the guy where is he
I'm still loving you um not together
with me but I know he did come here like
waited in a really long line to see you
made the whole pilgrimage with no guy
that's with you and thinking about me is
a fool that's what I'm saying right now